some bad news and some good news pt
won't be downloadable on the ps5 but the
new consoles fan will be optimized over
time
and even more good news the black ops
cold war beta has been
extended not a bad start to the week i'm
persia and this is your safe state for
monday october 19th
[Music]
pt is a coveted demo at this point so
unless you already have it saved on your
hard drive
you can't officially download it anymore
and the same goes for the ps5
since it isn't downloadable it also
means it isn't backwards compatible
either
konami gave an official statement to
game's radar saying the content
will not be available on the ps store so
users won't be able to re-download the
content through the backwards
compatibility feature
to the ps5 pt was removed from the
playstation store in 2015 and silent
hills fans are still clamoring for a
reboot
five years later but back in march
konami confirmed that it's just not
happening
we've all been there you boot up your
ps4 and the second you put it under any
stress
you're now sitting in front of a jet
engine ready for takeoff well hopefully
that's not gonna be the case with the
ps5
since sony said it will be optimizing
the fan over time
sony will collect data from the fan's
accelerated processing unit
allowing the fan to run at different
speeds depending on what's necessary for
whatever game you're playing at the time
so if the game makes the ps5 run hotter
for longer
the fan speed will increase to keep the
system cool
this news comes right after sony
released the official ps5 teardown video
and revealed the console's
new ui you can stay up to date on the
ps5 and all of the next-gen news on
gamespot's weekly show
generation x the current black ops cold
war beta was supposed to end today
october 19th
but it's been extended for another 24
hours
the beta is open to all players on ps4
xbox one
and pc ps4 players don't need ps plus to
try it but you do need xbox live gold
for the xbox version
and a battle.net account for pc as an
added bonus
all attachments are unlocked and there's
now double xp so it's the perfect time
to catch up if you missed out
the beta has team deathmatch hardpoint
kill confirm
control and the new combined arms and
dirty bomb modes
black ops cold war will be available
everywhere on november 13th
that's a wrap for monday's news hope you
had a great weekend
and if you want to see more of our daily
content then
hop on over to our channel and of course
don't forget to reach your next save
state tomorrow
see ya
[Music]